Speaker 1: Earlier this week, I mentioned to you
that Joe Biden has almost completely ended the
drone war, and it has barely made a headline.
Speaker 2: And we talked about some of the
Speaker 1: reasons why that is on the Monday show,
a Joe Biden has also overseen. I'm not saying,
caused no notice the language I'm using. Joe
Biden has also overseen some of the fastest
economic recovery in American history by
the metrics that Republicans love to use,
and that's also barely being discussed. There's
a really good article in the hill by our friend
Max Burns, who outlines this. And again, it's
by the standards used to judge the economy.
What's happening is quite notable. The economy
is now close to full employment unemployment,
Speaker 2: down from
Speaker 1: 6.7 a year ago to four point two in
the past. Similar declines have taken three
years, rather than one labor force participation.
Speaker 2: You know, a favorite of Republicans
Speaker 1: is at its highest level since the
pandemic. Wages are up in many industries.
Speaker 2: GDP growth is taking place,
Speaker 1: and somehow there is still significant
pessimism about the economy. Now, of course,
on right wing media, there's pessimism about
the economy, but also among Americans who
were just surveyed, polled and asked, What's
your general feeling about the economy now?
Does this mean there isn't suffering?
Speaker 2: Of course there are suffering.
Speaker 1: Does this mean we don't have
the same systemic economic issues about
fairness? Wages, overall inequality, health
insurance? We have all of those different things.
But by their standards, what's happening is
quite stunning. Remember, they talk about
unemployment rate, labor force participation,
Speaker 2: stock market as well, and stock
Speaker 1: market has been doing
very, very well. They also,
when it's a Republican in the White House,
Speaker 2: say that when there's good
Speaker 1: economic indicators, it's
thanks to the president that is in
Speaker 2: the White House with Joe Biden.
Speaker 1: I'm not even saying that I don't
Speaker 2: even have to.
Speaker 1: It's by their
standards. You attribute these things
Speaker 2: to the man or woman. Historically,
it's been a man who is in the
White House now. Is inflation
Speaker 1: increasingly
Speaker 2: an issue? It is.
Speaker 1: We talked about it yesterday
with Congressman Ro Khanna. It's an
Speaker 2: issue. It also
Speaker 1: is fair to say
that any particular individual's
Speaker 2: well-being is not
Speaker 1: totally coupled to
these broader economic indicators,
and that's true no matter who is president. Note
that I'm stepping back from is it a Democrat
or a Republican? The point here is not to say
Biden's a hero and fixed everything. In fact,
Speaker 2: he fixed nothing yet about the systemic
Speaker 1: economic issues that we face.
The other reason for
Speaker 2: pessimism is that,
Speaker 1: to be honest, there's some ignorance
about what a good economy even means. I mean, for
many people, they might have a job and be doing
fine, but they are aware that prices are going up.
Speaker 2: So when the poll
Speaker 1: asks them,
Are you pessimistic or optimistic about
the economy? They go, I'm pessimistic,
even though the inflation is not affecting
Speaker 2: them, and it's not. OK, well,
Speaker 1: if you can afford everything
and you're doing fine, is the economy doing
Speaker 2: poorly or not? Depends on what the
Speaker 1: scope of the question is. Are you
saying for me systemically, what are you actually
saying? 70 percent of the people polled said
they are doing fine but still feel the economy
is not good if it's fine for 70 percent. How
bad is it? And this isn't to minimize the
experience of those who are not doing well.
The point here is you've got by the standards they
Speaker 2: choose, things
Speaker 1: looking pretty good. And there are also
Speaker 2: these kind of polling artifacts
Speaker 1: in incongruities
Speaker 2: that don't necessarily
Speaker 1: prove or disprove
Speaker 2: the economy's good or the economy
Speaker 1: is bad. But it makes us wonder
when people are even asked these questions
what is making them say one thing versus
another? And often when you look into it,
Speaker 2: you know the right loves
Speaker 1: to make out to make a big deal out of
you can't trust polling when you're simply
asking, who are you going to vote for?
In fact, generally speaking, well sampled polls
which just say, who are you going to vote for
are mostly trustworthy. Generally
speaking, within the margin of error,
the polls that I think really we have to look
at with more skepticism are these opinion polls
about what is your sense of how this or that
is going, because often people will answer
Speaker 2: one way you ask them two or
Speaker 1: three questions and their actual nitty
gritty opinion would suggest they should have
answered the complete opposite way. So interesting
numbers. But in particular, interesting that
these are metrics where if it was a Republican
in the White House, they would be saying this is
unbelievable, and it's thanks to the Republican in
the White House. In this case, it's Biden. They're
certainly not attributing any of it to to Biden,
and they're not even really acknowledging that the
Speaker 2: numbers look pretty good.
Speaker 1: Send me your thoughts, let
Speaker 2: me know why and what you think is
Speaker 1: underlying this. You can find me on
Twitter at David Pakman and remember that next
Tuesday, the 14th. 6:00 p.m. Eastern. We'll be
doing our next viewer town hall. It'll be live on
the Pacman Live YouTube channel. Hope you'll join
me then? The David Pakman Show does count on great
people like you signing up for memberships on our
website at join Packman dot com, we do an extra
show every day called the bonus show for
our members. You also get a commercial
free audio and video feed of the show, if you
like, as well as other great member benefits.
Sign up at Join Packman dot com coupon code
available but not mandatory is better. 21.